[Music]
my next guest is a comedian who can be
seen live September 28th at the 30th at
Caroline's in New York and whose new
album super crazy is available now
please welcome the very funny Todd berry
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening
so I eat out every every meal
some people are heart to you with though
some people annoy the waitstaff with
annoying little requests like water with
lemon waitress comes by here's some
water for you oh not so fast I know you
think you just did the easiest thing
you're gonna do the entire night but I'm
gonna complicate it I really need some
lemon with my water you know the way I
drink it at home always slicing up a
lemon with each and every glass of water
I must go through 50 cutting boards a
month from all that relentless lemon
slicing gotta read those Yelp restaurant
reviews oh right
sometimes though I get too caught up in
the drama some heavy stories on Yelp
I'll be a mic I'm here like oh man it's
poor woman she went to this restaurant
for a birthday party that's always the
red flag in any Yelp restaurant mejia if
you see the words birthday party it's
gonna be a good one
she went to this restaurant for a
birthday party that at 7:00 o'clock
reservation all right they didn't get
seated till 7:15 no wonder she ran home
and ripped this place a new [ __ ] in a
scathing 13,000 word Riviera that
reveals 12,000 words in that the food
was actually really great
I don't eat right some people eat worse
than I do though saw guiding lunch she
had a burger fries milkshake beer
yeah burger and fries looked delicious
milkshake beer looked a little weird
even if you didn't care about your
health guys I can't gonna have a burger
fries a milkshake and a beer yeah both
those no not one or the other both Oh
trust me he's gonna be fine milkshake
and strawberry my favorite mmm suddenly
the worst beer I've ever had in my life
I don't eat you're right I'm a
germaphobe also yeah never dropped my
phone in the toilet that's a good thing
someone tells me they dropped their
phone in the toilet
their next sentence has to be so of
course I left it in the toilet because
it wouldn't even occur to me to reach
into a toilet to avoid buying a new
phone and don't tell me how you put in a
bowl of dry rice either but I put a bowl
of dry rice all the way a surgeon preps
his scalpels
I asked this woman she ever dropped her
phone I told her she goes I did but
there was no key in there really never
that is the luckiest series of events
ever they're installing a new toilet
you're first in line
the mayor cuts the ribbon the glare from
his scissors blinds you you slip you
fall where's that phone end up the
crystal-clear waters of an innocent
virgin toilets thanks a lot
[Applause]